Okay, so.
Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das oder Die Podcast Ufo, Ufinn. Wir freuen uns heute auf diese neue Folge. Wir haben uns die Stühle umgestellt, wir haben jetzt einen kleinen Raum zum Podcasten bekommen. Ich Pufo, du Pufos, er sie es Pufot, Pufomus, Pufamus, Pufatis, Pufant.
Alles falsch. Ach gut, du hast es jetzt konjugiert, ne?
Ich würde es nur sagen Pufo, Pufum, Pufo, Pufos, Puf, ne.
Pufo, Pufum, Pufo, Pufum, Pufos, Puforum, Pufis, Pufos, Pufis.
Wenn ihr in den Genuss kommen wollt, den lateinischen Beschreibungstext zu lesen, den Florentin sich ausdenkt, dann lernt doch mal bitte. Latein lebt, er hing immer ein Plakat im Lehrerzimmer, da hatte, glaube ich, jeder Liederlehrer so seine eigene Ecke, die er einrichten konnte. Der eine war Power Ranger Fan, der andere war offensichtlich Tom Cruise Fan, wirklich hatte alle Bilder, alle Autogrammkarten da und unser Lateinlehrer war natürlich Latein-Fan und hatte ein grosses Poster, wo irgendwie dann so Sokrates oder sowas dastand mit so einem grossen Globi in der Hand und dann stand da drauf Latein lebt. Und ich wollte immer sagen so, nee, per Definition nicht. Ich wollte gerade sagen, es gibt nicht so viele Plakate, wo man vorbeigehen kann, um zu sagen, nope. Ja, faktisch falsch. Faktisch falsch, weil viel, also normalerweise setzt sich das nicht durch, so viel Selbstbewusstsein, etwas Falsches zu sagen, sodass es durch viele Instanzen geht, um dann auf dem Plakat zu landen. Leukämie, Sie können helfen. Nope, kann ich nicht. Literally not. Aids, spenden Sie jetzt, wir besiegen Aids. Nein, würde ich bezweifeln. Ich finde auch gut, wenn man faktisch falsche Liebtexte schreibt. So Dinge drin, die einfach faktisch falsch sind, aber man trotzdem mitsingen muss, weil sie so catchy sind. Und dadurch so ein Anti-Wissen, ich will Anti-Wissen etablieren. Ja, gibt's ja. It's all about that bass, about that bass, about that bass. Das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt eigentlich. Das ist nicht immer nur mit dem Bass. Das ist völliger Quatsch. Das ist völlig ausgedacht. Was bedeutet Bass in dem Kontext? Weil in dem Lied geht es ja darum, dass fette Schnallen auch mal schön stolz auf ihren fetten, schwabbeligen Körper sein können. Und dann, it's all about the bass? About the bass, about the bass, no trouble. Weil die immer so einen Bass machen, wenn sie laufen, oder was? so bom badum da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da daLiedchen, in diesem Sternchen. In diesem, würde ich sagen, in der Krönung der Popmusik, diesem Werk, geht es glaube ich eher darum, dass man sagt, wir können aber alles singen, letztlich geht es nur um den Bass.
Und der ist folgendermassen, da haben die ja diesen Four on the floor beat, diesen
Because in the noise Es ist nur um den Bass. Und der ist folgendermaßen, da haben die ja diesen Four on the floor beat, diesen Four on the floor. Okay. Glaub ich, weiß ich nicht. Du hast das jetzt wunderschön musiktheoretisch aufgelöst. Ich sehe dich so ein bisschen in so einem schwarzen Konzertflügel so Pop-Songs zitiert. Wir haben uns jetzt nämlich mal in so einem Räumchen hier ein bisschen in die Ecke gesetzt, wo wir halt so schöne Lounge-Sessel haben.
Und da kommt man gleich in eine andere Stimmung.
Denn, was viele Podcaster ja nicht wissen, was ich weiß als großer Podcast-Guru, dass es immer ums Momentum geht.
Und wenn wir uns jetzt hier halt mal in so Lounge-Sessel setzen, fläzen, glaube ich, wird gleich was ganz anderes raus.
Das ist immer so.
Fläzen, lümmeln, würdest du dich gerade als lümmelnd bezeichnen oder als fläzend?
Ja.
Flacken, das glaube ich ist ein bayerischer Begriff. Kennst du den Begriff Zwitscheduri? Nee. Zwitscheduri? Draussen ist es gerade, würde man sagen, so ein bisschen Zwitscheduri. Stefan hat gerade beim Versuch zu trinken sein Mikrofon sich selbst ins Gesicht geschlagen. Aber wenn draußen das Wetter nicht ganz so gut ist, aber es ist auch nicht regnet zum Beispiel, dann sagt man, es ist zwitschidurig, bewölkt.
Und auffällig, wir sind genau gespiegelt in unserer Körperhaltung. Ich habe mein rechtes Bein auf mein linkes Knie gestützt, du andersrum. Bist du ein Linksbeiner oder was, oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Jetzt mal, hat das was mit Rechts- und Linksträger auch zu tun? Weil, macht das was aus? Ich weiß es nicht, aber tendenziell ist es, glaube ich, egal. Auch im Kino ist es halt immer so, dass ich mich quasi der Wille entsteht in meinem Unterbewusstsein, dieses Beinüberschlagen zu machen, aber nicht dieses vollständige Überschlagen, sondern diesen Fuss, Enkel, Fuss, Knöchel auf Knie, K auf K, K, K, K, K, und das entwickelt sich bei meinem Unterbewusstsein, wird dann aber bewusst ins Bewusstsein gespült, weil die sagen, fuck, das geht nicht, weil die Sitze für seine langen Beine viel zu nah aneinander sind. Und dann sagt das Unterbewusstsein, scheiße, spült so ein Bewusstsein und dann kommt so ein Blitz aus den Nerven in mein Gehirn geschossen, das mir sagt, ich habe gerade diesen Willen, diesen irrationalen Willen, meinen K auf K zu machen. Und dann muss ich ich halt so eine Tonübung machen. Ich muss mich im Sitz hochschieben, muss dann beide Beine hochnehmen ein bisschen und dann das quasi so, ich muss ein Bein zur Hilfe, ich muss eine Hand zur Hilfe nehmen. Och Gott, die Hand, das ist, diese K-of-K-Stellung drückt ja Coolness aus. Und ich wollte das immer machen, weil ich habe mir Etienne Gardet gesehen, der das gemacht hat. Der ist cool. War aber einfach lange Zeit einfach zu fett. Und nichts ist peinlicher als... Was? Man kann zu fett sein für diese Geste? Auf jeden Fall, klar. Du kannst einfach deine wulstigen Oberschenkel nicht aneinander drücken. Aber du konntest dich schon heben, weil die sind ja auch massig, die sind zwei Tonnen. Ich konnte ein Stück ja nicht heben. Und nichts ist unangenehmer. So einen Kran, einen großen Kran, der so meep, meep. So wie die Ritter früher, die damals auf ihre Pferde gehen. Das wird so romantisiert. Die waren, glaube ich, auch, wie haben die denn gekämpft? Ganz arme Hühner. Die mussten aufs Pferd von einem Kran gehoben worden, von so einem automatischen Kran, der dann so gepiept hat, da ging dann oben so eine Lampe an und dann wurden draufgehoben. Aber wie haben die denn gekämpft? Waren die denn agil im Kampf? Ich denke mal, wenn man so Kavallerieangriffe sieht, so ein Herr der Ringe oder so, wo wirklich tausende Reiter stürmen, ich denke mal so die Hälfte der Pferde denkt doch auch so, nope, ich gehe woanders hin und dann findet man sich in irgendeinem Wald wieder oder drehen um oder machen einfach gar nichts. Da gab es wahnsinnig viele Ausfälle. Das ist ja meine große Theorie bezüglich meiner Wenigkeit, dass man sich totstellen kann einfach. Ja, wir waren mal in einem Militärmuseum, Stefan und ich, in einem Waffenmuseum und alle haben gefragt, so hä, was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Speer und einer Hellebade und Stefan so, entschuldigen Sie bitte, ich habe eine Theorie, ich habe eine Theorie, ja wirklich zu Hellebaden, nein, zum allgemeinen Kampfwesen der menschlichen Geschichte. Man kann sich einfach totstellen. Das macht ja alles keinen Sinn. Ja, seitdem habe ich eine eigene Ecke im Museum dekorieren können, so wo die Stefan Stärfachgrosse Tizze-Theorie ist, die TT, wo da einfach ganz gross draufsteht, totstellen, ja, das geht. Totstellen, ja, sehr wohl mit mir. Und dann ist da so eine kleine Ecke, wo ich das demonstriere und dann kann der jeden Samstag von neun bis zehn Uhr bin ich im Deutsches Hörerische Museum in Berlin, könnte mich antreffen. Und ich führe dann ein kleines Happening. Ja, aber tatsächlich, was viele nicht wissen, es gab ja ein Volk, das diesen ganzen Zyklus durchgemacht hat. Die Etrusker sind ja tatsächlich in die Schlacht gestiefelt. Und dann hat es sich bei den Soldaten immer mehr etabliert, dass sich Leute totgestellt haben während der Schlacht. Und das hat sich natürlich rumgesprochen. Und irgendwann war es dann so weit, dass dieses Todstellen so populär war, dass sich die gesamte Armee totgestellt hat. Und dann war es ein sehr unangenehmes Wiederaufstehen, so ein Hi, hallo, hallo, hallo. Die hatten so einen Cyborg-Effekt, so Wow, wir haben alle besiegt, weil wir ihr Mutterschiff zerstört haben, jetzt sind alle umgefallen. Weißt du, wie bei Star Wars zum Beispiel, wenn dann das Mutterschiff zerstört wird, dann fallen die einfach um, wie so Roboter oder so Cyborgs. Bei Al-Robot zum Beispiel ist ist das Mythos der Roboterarmee, die man mit einem Schlag alle ausmachen kann. Was denken die denn, wenn vorhin so ein Heer einfach umfällt? Aber vom T-T nochmal zurück zum KfK. Ich war ja sehr fett und es gibt nichts Unangenehmeres als der missglückte KfK. Du willst deine wulstigen Beine übereinander schlängeln. Genau, der MKK. Du willst es und du schaffst es nicht ganz und du merkst, Krämpfe bilden sich schon beim nur kurzen Anheben. Und dann musst du kurz bevor du mit dem K das andere K erreichst, wieder abdrehen und wieder zurück zur Bodenstation und wieder absetzen. Das ist sehr unangenehm. Aber wie bespielst du das mit deinem Gesicht, dass du sagst, wow, ich kann keinen KfK machen und dann hast du einfach durchgezogen, hast einfach abgeworfen. Mir ist noch was eingefallen und dann stehe ich darauf auf, dann hebe ich meinen Wulstigen Körper. Um ein Stück Kuchen zu holen. Und das ist so ein Teufelskreis. Es ist wie ein Teufelskreis, ja. Immer wenn du es neu versuchst, dann denkst du, du hast ein bisschen was abgenommen und dann zack und wieder direkt ins Kuchenbuffet reingefallen. Bei mir ist es halt so, dass ich halt wie gesagt die Hand zu Hilfe nehmen muss, dann das Bein drüber schlängeln muss. Du kannst nicht das Hand zu Hilfe auf... Muss ich machen, sonst kann ich im Kino nicht über mein ein anderes Bein drüber. Was das so führt, dass mein Knie... Nee, probier es mal ohne Arm, das schaffst du doch. Nee, nicht wirklich. Nimm mal deinen Fuß. So. So müsst ihr es machen. Aber merkst du, was da passiert? Mein Oberkörper richtet sich auf, acht Meter nach oben. Dadurch kann die hinteren Zähne rein, kann nichts mehr sehen. Und mein Knie drückt halt vor den Vordermann immer so einem coolen Beat, dass der vor mir halt immer so nach vorne geworfen wird, während der Film läuft. Wie so ein 4D-Effekt, wenn gerade so eine Raumschlacht am Start ist, wird immer so nach vorne geschoben, geschubst von mir. Das ist eigentlich auch eine schlechte Aufgabe, dem Typen vor sich, während des Films zu vermitteln, man wäre in einem 4D-Film und danach der Kino so, ey, mega krass, wie der Sitz ist. Habt ihr das auch gehabt? Nein. Diese eine Person hat Spaß, aber dafür müssen fünf Personen auch mit so einem Föhn von hinten und dann so Geruchsstoffe. Eigentlich auch nicht schlecht. Wann gibt es das eigentlich? Es gab damals, es gibt erstaunlich viele Sprüche in so TV-Shows,
wo Leute sagen, ja, aber es gibt ja noch kein Geruchsfernsehen.
Warum nicht eigentlich?
Warum gibt es kein Geruchsfernsehen?
Weil man sagt ja auch, dass man die meisten Erinnerungen
und die besten, am stärksten widerrufen kann,
indem du etwas riechst.
Dann kommt dir die Erinnerung leichter in den Sinn,
weil die Synapsen da stärker zusammenhängen. Warum hast du das nicht durchgesetzt? Schwer zu sagen eigentlich. Frage an den Geruchsexperten, Doktor Nase. Hallo? Die Schedule. Hallo. Es ist so leicht manchmal. Zu leicht. Ich finde es ganz schön, dass du so umrahmt bist von lauter Gemälden, die an der Wand hängen. Du bist wie so ein sehr erfolgloser Praxisarzt, der keine Diplome hat und deswegen ganz viele Bilder an die Wand gehängt hat. Da, wo normalerweise Diplombilder sind, hat er einfach dann so Spiegel hingehängt. Guck mal, das ist ein Picasso-Bild, diese Eule. Ich finde es geil, wenn man einfach mal durch so ein Museum gehen würde, oder so eine Galerie, die gerade so eine Picasso-Ausstellung hat. Man hat manchmal einfach nur so schwarz-weiß Striche gemalt, so Comic-Buchfigur, quasi so eine Art, so ein bisschen Comic-esque Sachen. Stell dir mal vor, so ein Museum, da erlaubt sich ein Scherz, und man sieht die ganze Zeit so ein Bild, und dann irgendwann kommt Peter Griffin, und dann geht wieder weiter mit normalen Picasso-Bildern. Ja. Hat vielleicht sogar Picasso, hat er irgendwie Snoopy gemalt oder sowas? Das kann gut sein, vielleicht müssen wir da nochmal in alten Aufzeichnungen nachschauen. Stell dir mal vor, Picasso hätte damals so eine animierte Sitcom gekriegt, so family-mäßig. Hat er doch bestimmt Daumenkino, das berühmte Picasso-Daumenkino. Meinst du, er hat Angebote bekommen oder was? Meinst du, er hat Angebote bekommen? Klar, easy. Auch für so Background-Malerei und sowas, Bühnenbilder bestimmt. Nee, ich glaub, war hier so ... Von Twentieth Thumpiry Fox. Cothumpia, wegen Columbia, war ein bisschen zu weit weg. Guckt mal die Nachrichten von euch. Damals war das ja bestimmt ein großes Bild. Gab es eigentlich mal eine Hochzeit des Daumenkinos? Ich glaube, es gab nie eine Hochzeit des Daumenkinos. Es gab eine sehr lange Niederzeit des Daumenkinos. Und dann kurz mal so ein, der gesagt hat, nee. Es gab weder vom Daumenkino eine Hochzeit, glaube ich, noch von diesen Socken mit den Augen drauf. Davon gab es auch nie. Das sind so Dinge, da sind die Leute so augendrehend weggewandt von. Ja, es gibt ja tatsächlich, ich möchte mal kurz einen Ausflug in die YouTuber-Szene machen, es gibt da verschiedene YouTuber, die jetzt auch wahnsinnig viel Geld damit verdienen, auch jetzt eigene Produkte zu designen und Shampoos und T-Shirts und Modelinien, aber mein Lieblings-Youtuber Julian Bam hat sich entschieden, nee, ich bringe nicht irgendwie ein cooles Bandana, ein Stirnband oder irgendwie. Bandana. Das wäre cool gewesen. Zum Beispiel raus, nee,
der hat sich, ich habe den Namen schon vergessen, aber der hat
sich für so eine Holzzepter
entschieden. Bamboo.
Ja, der hat einen Holzzepter entschieden,
wo an der Schnur so eine Kugel ist
und dann musst du, dann hat er so ein
Holzkörbchen an dem Zepter und dann musst du den
Ball so hochflicken und dann mit dem
Ding auffangen. Und das ist seine Idee, um
als YouTuber Geld zu verdienen.
Ist das ein bisschen eine Anti-Idee?
Macht das nicht darüber lustig vielleicht?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Das ist ein Eis-Traddl.
Aber das ist wirklich so ein ...
Was ist der beschissenste Gegenstand der Weltgeschichte?
Und da kamen bestimmt auch Daumenkino mal.
Was ist das?
Das ist die Frage, die wir uns mit dem Podcast-Ufo-Shop
eigentlich immer stellen.
Was ist das schäbigste Produkt, das immer noch gekauft wird? Ich glaube, unfreiwillig, unser T-Shirt ist schon sehr nah dran. Oder die Warnweste. Nochmal, Shoutout an. Stimmt, wir haben eine Warnweste. Aber Shoutout an, das finde ich auch nicht schlecht, so ein Unfall. Ich nehme mal vor, so ein kleiner Familienvan ist auf dem Weg nach Holland. Der Papa hat die Luftmatratze eingebaut. Und dann, oh nein, der LKW drängt sich von der Autobahn ab, ein grausamer Unfall, oh nein, schnell das Warndreieck draufstellen, schnell die Warnwesten anziehen, die Mutter hat blutigen Oberkörper, sie werft sie doch schnell über, alle haben diese Podcast-Ufo- eine Podcast-Ufo-Warnweste an, obwohl sie leider vom Bau gefahren. Und dann werden sie leider vom Verkehr erfasst und dann will ich in den Nachrichten gross eine verbrannte, verkohlte Leiche sehen, die in eine Podcast-Ufo-Wahnweste angewickelt. Geil, wenn ich den Podcast-Ufo-Defibrillator finde ich gut, dann so Comedy einfach unangebracht ist. Oder dieses, wenn Leute einen anaphylaktischen Schock haben, so einen Allergieschock, einfach dann diese Spritze, dass einfach das Podcast-Ufo draufsteht. Einfach so Todesqualen oder so ein Inhalator, wenn Leute so einen Asthmaanfall haben. Das ist, finde ich, geiles Merchandise, wo Komödie am unangebrachtesten ist. Das ist eigentlich nicht schlecht so, da kann man einfach drüber nachdenken. Oder einfach so eine Bohrmaschine oder irgendwie sowas. Das sind einfach total schlechte Qualitäts. Wir müssen echt noch mal arbeiten. Shoutout an Donny O'Sullivan, der hat heute mit Netflix gesprochen und hat das Podcast-Sufo-Shirt an. Vielen, vielen Dank, mega coole Aktion. Leider ist es einfach wahnsinnig hässlich
und man erkennt auf keinem,
keinem Screenshot, den irgendwer uns geschickt hat,
dass es das Podcast-Ufo-Shirt ist, wenn man nicht weiss,
dass es das Podcast-Ufo-Shirt ist. Aber das ist ja auch der Sinn der Sache,
dass sich die Podcast-Ufo-Gemeinschaft geheim erkennen kann.
Wir haben ja auch mal dieses
Daumenzeichen eingeführt.
Unser Marketing-Chef ist gerade neben uns, hat sich hier erhangen.
Ja, das stimmt. Wir haben auch dieses Daumenzeichen
eingeführt, dass man die beiden Daumen der beiden Hände ruckartig aneinander führt. Das ist der Podcast-UFO-Erkennungsgruß. Wurde leider nicht so gut umgesetzt. Haben wir nicht mal, wir haben tatsächlich mal versucht, wir sind ja mittlerweile starke Running Gag-Verächter, sag ich mal, und im ewigen Kampf gegen den Running Gag. Wir haben aber mal tatsächlich versucht, einen Running Gag zu etablieren im Podcast-UFO. Ich fände es mega interessant, was jetzt die Zuschauer denken, was der Running Gag ist, den wir versucht haben zu etablieren. Aber, ich weiß nicht, ob du es weißt, Stefan. Ich höre zu. Der Begriff Smisma. Stimmt. Wir wollten mal den Begriff, wir wollten mal den, wir wollten so wie Seinfeld so Yada, Yada, Yada oder irgendwie sowas, was so popkulturell im Einklang gefunden hat. Ja, da so ein körbiges Pretty Pretty Pretty Pretty Girl. Sowas in der Richtung, wollten wir auch einführen. Und das haben wir versucht mit Smisma und haben wir versucht in den alten Folgen, ihr könnt es mal anhören, ich glaube von Folge 4 bis Folge 18 oder so, da haben wir kläglich einfach damit aufgehört, haben wir versucht irgendwie Smisma, ja ja, Smisma, so als, ne, von wegen so Lirum Larum. Ja, man muss sagen, Lirum Larum trifft den Nagel schon ganz gut auf den Knapp. Ziemlich perfekt eigentlich. Und Smeesma ist eigentlich nur Glose daran angelehnt. Ja. So unkreativ daran angelehnt. Ja, gut, Alter, war schon Smeesma. Also da haben wir versucht, ich werde es auf jeden Fall jetzt mit dem Hammer in euer Bewusstsein einstampfen. Kann man sowas erzwingen? Können wir nicht erst die Shirts machen und dann den Insider? Können wir nicht erst mit dem Sme-Smart-Shirt machen? Ich glaube, wir haben sogar noch das Textregiment von unseren ersten T-Shirts. Meine Idee war, so wie Run-DMC, so mit diesen roten Streifen oben unten, Smee-Smart zu machen. Vielleicht kann das mal jemand Design da draußen. Ab nächste Woche. Also Run-DMC oder Muse, das Muse-Logo ist auch so ähnlich, aber dann einfach oben Smee und ein Sma. Ja, einfach so der erfolgloseste Running-Gag der Geschichte einfach so. Aber drück doch mal irgendwie oben drauf so ganz kleinen Trademark das Podcast-Suche oder so, damit man sich erkennt. Ich glaube, Memes und Running Gags sind unmöglich zu erzwingen. Ich glaube, das geht per Definition nicht so. Da hat das Internet oder die Gesellschaft ihr eigenes Bewusstsein. Es ist, wie sich Spitznamen geben. Wie sich Spitznamen geben. Hast du ja auch schmerzlich festgelegt. Hunter hat sich nicht durchgesetzt. Aber mittlerweile schwappt es so ein bisschen rüber. Bambucha.
Das hat sich aber auch nicht durchgesetzt.
Bambucha oder was meinst du?
Bambucha. Trinke Fanta,
sei Bambucha. Was war das denn nochmal?
Ja, exakt. Und das ist nämlich genau das gleiche.
Das ist wie sich einen Spitznamen geben oder sich einen Running-Gag überlegen.
So Marketing-Kampagnen,
die gehen in 80% der Fälle nach hinten los einfach.
Trinke Fanta, sei Bambucha. Hat keinen Sinn gemacht, sollte weird sein weird sein, sollte auch glaube ich keinen Sinn machen, aber das hat sich auch nicht durchgesetzt.
Das stimmt, aber von Nike gab es doch auch mal irgendwie sowas, dieses Just Do It, der brillanteste.
Nee, wo dann Ronaldinho so krass gedribbelt hat und dann war irgendwie immer.
Wow, Achtung Leute, Florian begibt sich in unbekanntes Terrain.
Ich denke jetzt an Bon Jovi oder Bon Jova, aber es war was anderes so. Oh Mann, ey, wie hieß das nochmal? Omigatorium, Alcantara, Ariletto, Wolkenköpfchen, irgendwas in der Boni war, warte, ich komm da doch. Wir mussten an dieser Stelle zehn Minuten das Podcast ausschreiben. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Bonny, Bonn-Atoll, warte mal. Fühl mich ein, wo bist du gerade gedanklich? Bist du in der Werbewelt? Ja, ich bin in der Werbewelt und da gab es immer so ein Claim, wo so Sportmarken dann so ... wo Ronaldinho dann so krass gedribbelt hat als Achtjähriger und dann hat man das gefilmt im Nachhinein und dann hieß es noch so Ah, Mann, ey!
Du meinst ein Fussballer jetzt oder sowas?
Nein, da gab es dann so einen Spruch,
irgend so was Brasilianisches, so Ruf mal Philipp Hauptmann an. Bonita
Jogi Bonita!
Yes!
Oder, Leute!
Jogi Bonita? Hä?
Was soll das denn bedeuten? Warte mal, Jogi bin ich jetzt komplett bescheuert. Warte, warte, warte, warte, warte. Das ist doch irgendwie so ein, der Unterbewusstsein hat so ein Anagramm gebildet. Das ist Anagramm von Ich hab Hunger oder sowas. Gebt mir noch mehr Kuchen. Nee, nicht Jogi Bonita. Ach shit, ey, fuck.
Aber das könnt ihr auch schon mal direkt auf die T-Shirts drucken.
Was war, komm, du weißt da, was ich meine.
Nein, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo du sprichst. Aber Bambucha, ey.
Aber das kennt man noch, ne?
Aber sonst weiss man nicht.
Das Ding ist ja auch, die Schwierigkeit jetzt, Beispiele dafür zu finden, für Werbeclames, die nicht funktioniert haben, ist ja, dass deren Quintessenz ist, nicht funktioniert zu haben. Nennt mir jemanden eine unbekannte Band. Ja. Na gut, fangen wir jetzt drei ein aufgrund meiner grandiosen Vergangenheit. Und drei war die größte Zahl, ich mir eingefallen. Das war tatsächlich, ich habe ja früher die Simpsons Comics gelesen, und manchmal, die sind ja rückblickend nicht so wahnsinnig lustig und so, aber manchmal war da so ein Gag drin und da gab es einen Gag, es gibt glaube ich aus meiner Kindheit so bestimmt so zehn Gags, an die ich mich erinnere die kriegen jetzt nicht alle zusammen natürlich, aber wo ich mir wirklich lange dachte, so das ist ein genialer Gag das ist brillant und einer der besten Gags, vielleicht war es aus der Serie oder aus Seinfeld, keine Ahnung oder aus Bruce Allmächtig oder sowas und irgendwann Dokumentation von Daumenkino. Und da gab es eine Szene im Schulbus und dann sagt der Schulbusmeister, sagt dann sowas wie, ja sind alle da, können wir losfahren? Und dann sagt der Schulbus Erster Mart, sagt dann sowas wie, wer nicht da ist, sagt hier. Und dann sagt niemand hier und dann sagt, ja okay, alle da, wir fahren los. Und du saßt da in deinem Strandkorb. Das darf doch nicht wahr sein. Ich mache was mit Comedy. Das war wirklich so ein Erleuchtungsman. Wurde man auch nicht lacht, ne? Ganz, sorry. Okay, pass, alles gut. Nee, passt schon. Aber das war tatsächlich einer der Gags. Erinnerst du dich an Gags aus deiner Kindheit? Worüber hat der 14-jährige Stefan gelacht? Laut gelacht. Bei mir war King of Queens ganz oben in der Liste. Und ich finde es so lustig, da gibt es eine Folge, die fängt an, das Code Opening ist, wie Doug Hathenon seinen Anrufbeantworte erreichen will und da einfach dann zu Hause bei sich durchklingeln muss. Und Arthur immer rangeht und es über zehn Minuten lang geht, was eine lächerliche Zeit ist für diesen einen Gänge. Aber die melken den. Ich finde es so lustig und finde ich immer noch super lustig, weil am Ende artet es einfach so ein Geschrei aus, weil Arthur dann auch wieder rangeht und dann sagt er, okay, es ist halt Gewohnheit, geht dann aber in die Küche, um davor zu fliehen, aber da hängt dann auch noch ein Telefon und er geht wieder dran, was auch grandioses Timing ist. Wow. Der Vater von Ben Stiller. Jerry Stiller. Ja, Jerry. Das ist übrigens der Onkel von Jerry Seinfeld. Nein. Wegen Jerry. Das war jetzt wahrscheinlich, viele hatten da draußen jetzt wahrscheinlich genauso den Moment wie ich damals, dass sie am Strand liegen und denken so wow bist du so ein Strandtyp, so ein Strandkorbtyp ich kann mich nicht gut vorstellen, wie du mit so einer kleinen, aber also etwas altbodischen, aber noch nicht zu alten Badehose da so hängst, dann schön dir so ein Bierchen aufgemacht hast, schön die Bild-Zeitung auf und dann so ein Strandkorb liegst. Ich bin ja der jüngste meiner drei Brüder. Das heißt, ich bin der jüngste der Kinder meiner Eltern. Ja, das haben alle schon beim ersten Mal verstanden. Das heißt, du bist ja quasi der am zuletzt geborenste deiner Eltern Nachkommen. Das heißt, meine Eltern sind überdurchschnittlich alt im Vergleich zu mir. Ich habe relativ alte Eltern. Ja, habe ich auch. So, und jetzt war ich mal am Strand, da waren wir in Urlaub und dann war so die Nachbarsfamilie, da hatten wir so Urlaubshäuser und die Nachbarsfamilie, da habe ich mit den Kindern so abgehangen und dann haben die mal gesagt so, hey, hast du nicht Bock, irgendwie mit uns zum Strand zu kommen eines Tages? Bin ich dann mitgegangen, dann sind wir da zum Strand gegangen, irgendwie Handtuch aufgebreitet, hingelegt und dann irgendwie sowas und dann habe ich dann dann letztens gesagt, so ja, keine Ahnung, habe ich erzählt, ja, wir waren einkaufen und ich war mit meinem Vater im Urlaub. Okay, ich bin bereit. Aber es ist, dass du mittlerweile so alt bist, dass deine Körpergeräusche und deine Aufstossgeräusche mittlerweile einfach so einfach so eine Story kaputt machen, weil was ist denn jetzt passiert? Und auf jeden Fall die Family Guy, Cutaway, wo er diese Dad-Neusses macht die ganze Zeit und dann einfach die ganze Zeit nur in seinem Sessel sitzt und so wie Ja, ja. Und das ist mittlerweile auch Florian. Wenn man ihm so beim Leben zuguckt, denkt man die ganze Zeit, wow, die letzten Jahre. Also sowieso wie immer Strand. Aber ja auch. Und es kommt trotzdem wieder in so ein Best-of von so einem Scheiß. Weißt du, dann macht man trotzdem wieder ein Best-of aus deinem Anekdötchen. So, das ist trotzdem. Das ist immer noch besser als die beste Stefan-Geschichte für Leute. Aber um es ganz kurz zu Ende zu bringen. Ja, bitte. Dann war ich am Strand und ich war mit meinem Vater im Urlaub, er war aber nicht dabei am Strand. Und dann hat dieser andere Junge zu mir gesagt, da meinte ich eben, habe ich da kurz... Die schlechteste Anekdote aller Zeiten, alten, alten. Nein, weil meine Brüder sind älter als ich. Ja, verdammt. Storytelling vom Meister. Er schreibt beruflich Drehbücher. Und auf jeden Fall, also mein Vater war nicht mit am Strand, aber ich war mit dem Nachbarsjungen. Ja! Und ich glaube, wir waren halt so ein, zwei Tage oder so gerade im Urlaub in diesem Urlaubshaus. Und dann sind wir halt zum Strand gegangen. Und dann meinte der so, aber ich hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt schon irgendwie alles ausgebreitet, also ich hatte dann irgendwie meine Badehose dabei, meine Schwimmnudel, Poolnudel, alles dabei. Und dann lege ich mich da so hin und wir kommen halt so ein bisschen ins Gespräch und ich erzähle ihm halt so nebenbei, jetzt nicht irgendwie von wegen so, oh, das musst du jetzt unbedingt hören, sondern halt einfach so nebenbei habe ich irgendwie erwähnt, dass ich einkaufen war und dann hat er, also die,
das andere Kinder dann gefragt so, ah, warst du einkaufen mit deinem Opa? Und ich so, nee, das ist mein Lieblingspodcast, die erzählen immer lustige Sachen. Abspann. Aber jetzt müsste der Abspann kommen. So acht Minuten lang Credits und der Kameramann. Aber auf jeden Fall war dann die Stimmung zwischen uns aus irgendeinem Grund so schlecht, dass ich irgendwann wieder gegangen bin, weil das so unangenehm war, dass dieses Oh, sorry, okay, dein Vater, das ist im Raum. Und irgendwann bin ich einfach gegangen und seitdem war ich nie wieder an einem Strand. War ich da einfach eine schlechte Erfahrung gemacht. Oh Mann. Okay. Ich glaube, eine Anekdote schafft man. Es war ja Karneval. Und wer uns kennt, weiß, wir lieben Karneval. Wir gehen feiern Karneval. Was hast du dieses Jahr, was bist du gegangen? Ich war in Hamburg, bin geflohen, komplett, hab mich nicht interessiert. Es waren dieses Jahr, habe ich das Gefühl gehabt, viele so diese ironischen Kostüme, die sind ja sowieso immer ironisch, aber da gab es halt, bei Facebook hat man das ja gesehen, diese kleinen Männer, diese kleinen Männer, die einen Mann auf dem Kopf tragen, das war dieses kleine Kostüm, was so die Arme von sich trägt. Ich fall jedes Mal drauf rein. Wo ich mir jedes Mal das denke, wow, ein lustiger Zwerg, der einen Mann auf dem Kopf hat. Hör, der reitet auf einem Hund. Jedes Mal lustig. Aber das habe ich dieses Jahr ein paar Mal gesehen. Ich bin auch geflohen, ich habe auch nicht so viel davon mitbekommen. Aber ich finde es so lustig, einfach dann, man kriegt halt, obwohl ich in Köln wohne, halt das nur am Rande mit, weil ich morgen zur Arbeit komme und abends wieder fahre.
Und da kriege ich halt dann ein bisschen was mit aus der U-Bahn, aber dann ist halt schon diese Feierlaune in den Gesichtern verflogen. Und ich finde es jedes Mal aufs Neue herrlich, wie dann der Dino mit seinen lustigen großen Antennen in der Bahn sitzt und einfach sauer ist. Das ist immer wieder das Grösste. Das ist einfach wunderschön, ja. Ich war im Zug unterwegs auf dem Weg nach Hamburg im ICE und es gab große Wetterprobleme und alle haben sich beschwert über den Ausfall der Züge und es ist einfach nichts Schöneres, als irgendwie so ein süsses Maikäferchen zu sehen, dass er auf den Schaffner einbrüllt und dabei wackeln die Fühler so süss und du denkst einfach so, ja, einfach die Definition von ich kann sie gerade nicht ernst nehmen. Aber dann müssen sie auch in der Rolle bleiben, finde ich. Da muss man sagen, ich habe nicht meine 18.000 Maikäferkinder. Die Eier habe ich nicht nur gelegt, um hier jetzt in der Bahn zu sitzen, um zu spät nach Hamburg zu kommen. Und so lustige Sachen dann. Ich erinnere mich noch an Fasching. Ich komme aus Bayern, da hieß es Fasching. Lächer mich. Da bin ich mal als Harry Potter gegangen. Aber ich kann mich noch erinnern, ich habe damals Du bist als Dudley gegangen, du bist unfreiwillig als Neville gegangen. Ich bin 364 Tage meines Lebens als Dudley gegangen, aber am letzten wollte ich dann doch nochmal als Harry gehen, als Held der Geschichte. Harry. Und wir haben, also ich habe lange Harry Potter gesagt, weil du liest das Buch, wo er solltet ihr wissen, dass der Harry heißt.
Mein Vater, der ist ablehnend, Englisch zu sprechen und er sagt, dieses Buch ist auf Deutsch geschrieben, also heißen die Namen auch auf Deutsch und dann habe ich ihn gefragt und er hat diese ganzen Dan Brown Bücher gelesen, übrigens auch an der Ostsee, als ich noch jünger war, am Strandkorb. Und dann steht auf der deutschen Fassung auch Dan Brown.
Dan Brown hat die Bücher geschrieben und hat die gel. Und dann hat er die ganze Zeit gesagt, was ist heute passiert, was hast du gelesen? Ja, Robert Langdon, der ist dann, Langdon ist durch die Stadt gelaufen und hat drei Rätsel gelöst. Das war immer Robert Langdon. Deswegen war es für mich ganz seltsam, die Filme zu sehen plötzlich, wo es Robert Langdon gesagt haben, wo ich erst mal dachte, wow, ganz kurz, Filmschnitt. Das kennt man heute gar nicht mehr, wenn man einfach so mit PR-Material vollgeballert wird, aber zum Beispiel als die neue Konsole nach dem Gamecube von Nintendo auf dem Markt war, ich hab die lange Y-Eye genannt, Y-Eye, weil ich nicht wusste, wie man das ausspricht, Y-Eye. Und weil du dich selber in Frage stellst. Und irgendwann hieß es dann so, wie? Und ich so, jo, ich bin voll Idiot. So sagt man dazu. Früher als Kind habe ich dann viel zu früh für mein Alter, habe ich diesen grauenvollen Roman Puls von Stephen King gelesen und der spielte halt die ganze Zeit in Massachussetts. Massachussetts die ganze Zeit. Bis ich irgendwann mal gesagt habe, wow, habe ich Leuten von meiner Geschichte erzählt, wow, und dann geht es um Handyverrückte und die haben alle so ein Signal gehört und sind alle auf Reset gesetzt worden und das ganze Spiel die Massachussetts in den USA, kennt ihr vielleicht, wenn ihr so ein großes Staat, alles so, es heißt Massachusetts. Das sind diese Dinge, die man dann liest nur, die kann man dann lesen. Aber bei mir war es lange Harry Potter und dann irgendwann habe ich angefangen, die englischen Bücher zu lesen und Hermione. Hermione. Hermione. Bei mir war es Hermione und ich dachte mir, where the fuck is Hermione two? Hermione two, where is she? Hermione one, einfach so keine Chance. Ron ja. Das ging jetzt nicht, ne? Ja, Ron ist schwierig, falsch auszuprobieren. Ron, ne, ich dachte jetzt auch wegen One. Gibt's eigentlich so ein T-Shirt, gibt's eigentlich Ron-DMC und dann so Ron Weasley irgendwie, so einen coolen Streetstyle? Das Problem ist ja, dass neben dem Ron-DMC kein Gesicht mehr zu sehen ist, also wäre das per se wahrscheinlich ein Gag der Unmöglichkeit. Okay. Ein weiterer Gag der Unmöglichkeit. Aber ganz kurz, ich wollte es nur abschliessen, ich war auf dem Fasching und habe mich als Harry Potter verkleidet, aber man wusste nicht, wie Harry Potter aussieht. Also du wusstest jetzt nicht, wie die ganzen Uniformen aussehen und was die so für Sachen tragen. Ach so, weil das so früh war. Ja genau, ich hatte nur das Buchcover und dieses Buchcover habe ich letztes Mal wieder gesehen, so dieses uralte Buchcover, so mit diesem Comic-Harry. Mit diesem Gesicht, was sich immer so reinschiebt von unten. Richtig, die Fotobomb einfach so, hallo! Man denkt immer nur, erst war das Foto da, von diesem toll schönen Schloss und plötzlich kam einfach so ein Typ, der sich so aus dem Untergrund hochgeschoben hat plötzlich und dann da war. Aber gut, finde ich so ein großes Panorama von so einem Schloss und Harry steht so ganz klein an einem Fenster und an so einem Pfeil so, da, da ist der Protagonist. Es ist immer unrealistisch, dass der Protagonist ganz weit weg ist von der Akademie und dann so reinguckt. Auf jeden Fall sah ich total bescheuert aus. Ich hatte so einen Hexenhut auf, ich hatte so einen Glas-Zauberstab in der Hand, wo so Glitzer hin und her geflossen ist in dem Stab. Ich hatte einen Umhang auf, ich war irgendwie so als halbe Hexe geschminkt und so bin ich als Harry Potter gelaufen und irgendwann habe ich dann gemerkt, das kommt nicht an und dann immer gesagt so, hä, und dann haben alle Kinder gefragt und was bist du und so, ja, das ist was aus Star Wars, aber das kennen nicht viele. Trottel. Unsichtbar, man ist unsichtbar, jetzt immerhin weggegangen. Oh, auch nicht schlecht, man braucht, um als Harry Potter zu gehen, eigentlich nur möglichst viele Tapeten, so tapetengemusterte Umhänge, um dann möglichst überall, du weißt ja eigentlich, wo du, in welcher WG-Fighter landest am Ende, einfach mal kurz vorher ein Foto aus der WG bei Facebook stalken, kleiner Tipp hier an der Stelle, Fasching-Tipp, kurz gucken, was sind die von den Tapeten und dann dementsprechend eine Decke besorgen und dann den Tarno-Mann von Harry Potter umsetzen und dann sieht man dich nicht. Oder einfach kurz fragen, so könnt ihr mir kurz ein paar Bilder von euren Wänden schicken im Vorhinein.
Das ist generell auch immer
eine gute Frage, aber diese Frage stellt man sich ja eh vorher.
Die erste Frage, die ich stelle,
nach wann kann ich kommen, ist
wann kann ich wieder gehen und die dritte Frage
ist, was habt ihr eigentlich für Wände?
Das ist eigentlich auch eine schlechte, die man fragen kann, so hey, hast du Bock,
ob ich die Party zu kommen? Ja klar, wann kann ich wieder gehen?
So ab zehn, okay, cool.
Ich finde, neulich habe ich mal eine Einladung bekommen,
wo unüblicherweise drauf stand,
bis wann die Party geht. Ah ja.
Finde ich super cool. Mega gut.
Du weißt, du kannst 20 Minuten davor kommen
und dann so, hey Leute, ja, ich kam noch von einer anderen Party
und dann, oh, jetzt schon echt krass,
ich hätte noch die Nacht durchgefeiert, dance and lay the way,
wir gehen noch in die Bar.
Alles klar. Ich liebe Partys
mittlerweile, die von Familienvätern gemacht werden, weil man weiß, die gehen nicht lang. Die können bei der Finition nicht lange gehen. Und dann heißt es irgendwann, wir haben das Kind der Nachbarin gegeben. Oh, fuck. Scheiße. Ich würde heute Abend ein Kollege von uns feiern heute Abschied und unsere ganzen Kollegen feiern und saufen gerade und wir sind pflichtbewusst und nehmen hier einen Podcast auf. Ich liebe das gerade, ich liebe das, die beste Ausrede zu haben, einfach eine Ausrede zu haben, die nicht gelogen ist. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das ändert ja nichts. Also wir sagen jetzt, wir müssen einen Podcast aufnehmen, sonst darf ich auch einen Podcast aufnehmen, aber jetzt fühle ich mich nicht schlecht, weil ich es wirklich mache. Und ich wurde vorhin von zwei extrem attraktiven Kolleginnen gefragt, so hey, wir feiern irgendwie noch, hast du Bock, irgendwas trinken zu kommen? Susi, Hannah, ihr wisst, ihr wisst. Und ich so, nee, sorry, ich muss noch einen Podcast aufnehmen und so und alle so, ja, ja, ja, aber ich dachte so, ihr könnt ja danach anhören, der existiert ja, das ist ja Beweis.
Und dann haben die mich...
Falls ihr euch fragt, warum Florian nicht so wahnsinnig beliebt ist in der Firma?
Dann aufgrund solcher Speeches.
Ah, schon lustig.
Ist schon immer lustig.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, da sagst du was. Was ist das an der Wand da? Das frage ich mich immer, wenn wir in diesem Raum sind. Das ist die Flucht der Karibik-Münze. Da ist einfach nur, hängt so tellerförmig wie ein Bild, als wäre es ein Bild, hängt an der Wand so eine große Medaillon. So ein riesengroßes, goldenes, wie das Flucht der Karibik-Medaillon. Ich habe Flucht der Karibik ja 13 Mal im Kino gesehen und ich dachte mir immer so, je häufiger du irgendwas siehst, desto unrealistischer wird, weil du irgendwie immer so Details raussiehst. Und über einen Grossteil des Filmes trägt ja Elizabeth Swann die Münze um ihren Hals als Kette. Und ich dachte mir immer so, hä, das sind doch Goldmünzen. Warum sind da Löcher drin? Und dann irgendwann später sieht man, dass sie die auch reinwirft, wieder in diese große Schatztruhe zu den anderen Münzen. Und da sieht man, ja, in allen anderen sind natürlich keine Löcher drin, weil das sind Goldmünzen, da sind keine Löcher drin. Und ich habe auch 180 Mal diesen Film gesehen und ich habe mich jedes Mal gefragt, wie Jack Sparrow, da gibt es diese, wenn du den Film so oft gesehen hast wie ich, den kennst du diese Szene, wo er am Anfang flieht. So, und dann gibt es nämlich wieder zum ersten Mal von, ich meine, ist es nicht Cutler-Backett oder so, wird er festgenommen in dem Dorf und dann hat er diese berühmte Verfolgungsjagd, die er in der Stadt, die er zu Will führt. Genau, wo er Elisabeth als Geisel nimmt erst und dann flieht. So, und dann gibt es diese Szene, wo er erstens, ich halte die komplett erlogen und erstunken. Erfunden, gar? Komplett erfunden, würde ich sagen. Das ist so nicht passiert im Original. In der Bibel stand das so nicht. So, macht er diese Geste, wo er dann auf so ein kleines Rad dreht, auf dem Steg, und dann dreht sich das und dann wird er hochgezogen von so einem Kran. Ja, da fährt die Kanone runter und das Gegengewicht zieht er sich dann hoch. Dann läuft er ein bisschen, dann wird er erstmal, dreht er sich dann im Kreis und die Leute schießen auf ihn. Und das halte ich, dass sie nicht treffen, verstehe ich nicht, weil erstmal drehen sie auf Augenhöhe und dann dreht er sich ja, wenn er von denen weg sich dreht, haben die eigentlich ungefähr zwei Sekunden lang freies Schussfeld. Naja gut, geschenkt, gekauft. Filmlogik, ja. Dann rennt er ein bisschen, habe ich nie verstanden, er hat Handschellen. Ja. So, und dann plötzlich gibt es dieses Seil und er hängt sich dran und wirrt und reisst über den ganzen See, so Tarzan- mässig, an dieser Seil, so eine Seilbahn halt. Aber er hat ja quasi einen Hohlraum, das heißt die Handschellen bilden mit seinem Armen und seiner Brust ein O. Wie kann er da jetzt drüber? Und zwar macht er dann einfach, aber dafür ist die Kette nicht lang genug, er schmeißt es so drüber, nimmt dann das andere Ende. Genau, so macht er es, ja. Ich habe es mir extra noch mal angeguckt. Ich auch. Ich habe es mir extra mal angeguckt, aber er führt die Handgelenke zusammen und durch die stehende Schlaufe wirft er die über das Seil und hält die Schlaufe auf der anderen Seite fest. Was eine geniale Idee. Ich habe das damals im Filmfehlerforum tatsächlich diskutiert. Fehler minus im minusfilm.de habe ich mich lange rumgetrieben im Filmfehlerforum und solche Sachen rausgeguckt, weil ich sehr einsam war. Das ist der Hauptgrund und mir einfach Filme ruinieren wollte. Das sind die schlimmsten Menschen, die Filmfehler suchen. Das ist grausam. Die einzige Freude, die man an Filmen hat, ist sich der Fiktion hinzugeben und dann zu sagen, wir suchen jetzt einen Fehler da drin, ist das furchtbar. Du bist ein Unmensch. Ich kenn's den Leuten aus deinem Scheißforum auch. Ich weiß, ich war ein Riesenarschlauch, ich war früher Agnizismusgegner, hab jeden korrigiert, der irgendwas gesagt hat. Und auch hier, Jack Spatz, irgendwie wäre das so nicht durchgekommen. Das gab's zum Beispiel in WoW, in World of Warcraft, gab's eine große Lokalisierung, dass alles aus dem Englischen ins Deutsche übersetzt wurde und auch die Eigennamen der Charaktere. Also da gibt es dann eine Jaina Proudmoore, die heißt dann später Jaina Prachtmeer. Also ihr Name wurde auch einfach übersetzt. Jeder weiß, dass Moore mehr heißt. Ja, das ist genau so, wenn du Jack Sparrow halt in Jack Specht übersetzen würdest, der halt dann schon mal nicht mehr so cool ist. Es wäre auch nicht Jack. Jack Spatz. Das würde ich mal behaupten, es wäre auch nicht Jack. Jakob Spatz. Ja, es wäre Jakob Spatz, der gegen Kapitän Jakob Spatz, der gegen Wilhelm Dreher kämpft. Und Elisabeth Schwan. Erleben zusammen eine romantische eine romantische Reise. Wilhelm Dreher und Jakob Specht auf großer Reise.
Aber zusammen wollen sie die Goldmünzen des fiesen Barbarossa auf der schwarzen Perle besorgen. Aber genau so war das damals auch, da haben sie sich viele darüber aufgeregt, aber ich war da Parteilinie, ich habe auch alle nur noch beim übersetzten Namen genannt, das war dann auch für mich völlig in Ordnung. Ja, war eine harte Zeit, aber auch scheissegal, wenn man drüber nachdenkt, auch ziemlich scheissegal. Aber warum erzählen überhaupt euch Dinge? Erzähl uns doch mal was. Ey, lass uns mal wieder auf Kommentare eingehen. Ja, au ja, das ist immer so viel lustig. Die Podcast-UFO-Kommitator. Ist ja nicht so, dass ich da immer unseren Hass rausschneiden muss, den wir plötzlich verfallen. Danke für eure Epidemiologie übrigens, die Gewinnerin hast gemeldet, ne? Gehe ich recht in der Annahme? Ja. Also Nina, Laura oder Rebecca oder ein Hammer. Ach ja, übrigens das große Paypal-Update, mal ganz kurz. Ganz kurz, dass wir es ganz mal abgehakt haben, das Konto wurde eingefroren und wir stehen im rechtlichen Clinch mit Paypal. Wenn also irgendwer da draußen Anwalt ist oder und oder jemanden bei PayPal kennt, wir erreichen da niemanden. Die Rechtsabteilung schottet sich komplett ab von uns. Die wollen nicht mit uns sprechen. Das Service Center lässt mich nicht mit der Rechtsabteilung sprechen, die unser Konto komplett eingefroren haben. Das ist ein Riesenscheiß, der da passiert ist. Das Geld rauf im Konto, das haben wir jetzt offensichtlich verloren. Und dann kam es zu der Situation, wo man mir gesagt hat am Telefon, ja, wir haben sie gesperrt, sie bekommen aber das Geld, wenn das ihr Konto ist, nach 180 Tagen aufs Konto geschrieben. Und dann habe ich kurz einen Moment gehabt, wo ich dann ruhig war am Telefon, und dann habe ich mich aufgeregt darüber, weil ich mir ganz kurz überlegen musste, ob das richtig ist, dass die das machen können, Weil da ist viel Geld drauf und die haben gesagt, dann kriegen sie es in 180 Tagen. Da habe ich kurz überlegt, 80 durch 30, das sind ungefähr sechs Monate. Sechs Monate ist ein halbes Jahr. Können die das machen? Ein halbes Jahr, können die ein halbes Jahr unser Geld? Da habe ich gesagt, das ist ja. Sie können doch nicht uns ein halbes Jahr das Geld wegnehmen. Da habe ich mir kurz überlegt, ob man das mal sagen kann. Da habe ich gesagt, und dann hat der andere gesagt, ja, da haben Sie recht, das ist eine sehr lange Zeit. Gott sei Dank, ist es eine lange ... Weil ich habe keine Referenzen in meinem Leben. Ich habe keine Referenzen. Der Grund, warum ich eigentlich eine Freundin brauche, scheiß auf diese ganzen anderen Sachen so, wo man hat jemanden in seinem Leben, fuck it, brauche ich nicht. Ich brauche jemanden, der mir sagt, wo man so ganz, ganz, ganz die Ohrmuschel zuhält und dann... Schatz, 80 Cent für einen Liter Milch, ist das viel oder ist das wenig? Diese Avokale kostet 20 Euro, ich habe jeglichen Sinn fürs Geld verloren, weil ich reich bin. Ist das viel oder wenig? Und ich habe keine Referenz gehabt. 180 Tage haben wir kein Geld mehr. Keine Ahnung. Können die das mit mir machen? Das ist, das darf doch wohl nicht wahr sein. Wirklich so 50-50, so yay oder was. Woran liegt das denn, dass wir so weltfremd sind? Ja, keine Ahnung. Wir leben so in so einem eigenen Elfenbeintürm. Ja, ich glaube, keine Ahnung. Auch ist Elfenbein so wertvoll? Weiß ich nicht. Gibt's das? Ist das ein Sprichwort? Man weiss es einfach nicht. Wir schauen mal ganz kurz, wir versuchen mal ein bisschen auf den Boden der Tatsachen zurückzukommen und das machen wir immer durch unsere räudige Community und zwar Ich lese einfach mal den letzten ... Kannst du mal unschalt aufwenden, mein fucking Dingel, die ganze Zeit reinzuhalten. Ich wusste nicht, ob du dich räusperst oder ob das ein Intro sein soll.
Ich lese einfach mal den letzten Kommentar vor, der kommt von Damien Chazelle, nee von Chalmion Dezelle, funny, funny, funny, cause it's a wrong name, der schreibt, ihr seid immer am lustigsten, wenn ihr euch selbst und das, was ihr sagt, nicht ernst nehmt. Wenn es dann um sowas wie eine ernst gemeinte Diskussion geht, muss ich mit den Augen rollen.
Das, was schon etliche Male woanders gesagt wird, wird hier als intelligente Analyse behandelt. Es wäre wenigstens interessant, wenn ihr euch gegenseitig nicht immer nickend zustimmen oder einfach mal den anderen Standpunkt vertreten würdet. Er muss nochmal dazu sagen, wir stimmen uns zu, weil wir beide massiv intelligent sind, massiv reflektiert sind und die objektiv richtige Meinung immer haben. Was soll das denn heißen? Einstein, E ist gleich im Ziel Quadrat. Nee, Entschuldigung, Albert, da muss ich jetzt ganz kurz mal den Gegenstandpunkt vertreten. Ich glaube, wenn du darüber nachdenkst, dann das wurde überall schon mal gesagt und du solltest mir was eigenes ausdenken. Ja, nur das ist halt blöd. Widersprechen des Widersprechenswillens führt halt nirgendwo hin. So, und auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir, wir sind ähnlich sozialisiert, haben ähnliches Leben, natürlich stimmen wir uns mal mehr zu.
Auf der anderen Seite stellen wir aber auch nicht unsere Theorien als die super Sachen dar.
Nee, das ist im Gegenteil. Das ist ein räudiger Podcast einfach so. Das ist hier wirklich untere Ritterklasse.
Das ist ein Lumpen-Podcast.
Ihr müsst euch auch nicht immer so schick machen. Zieh euch mal eine Jogginghose an oder irgendwie mal so eine schöne Schlauerpulli oder einfach mal so einen Bademantel. Geht es nicht auch so, dass du am liebsten im Bademantel leben würdest? Boah, ich hatte lange Zeit einen Bademantel und der war richtig gross und es gab nichts Cooleres als Treppen runterzulaufen mit diesem wehenden Bademantel, splitternackt in dem wehenden Bademantel. Mit so einem Cognac-Schwenker in der Hand. Ja, oder ich hatte halt immer so eine Schüssel Koffleks. Weißt du, was mein Leben beschreiben soll man irgendwann? Ich will folgenden Satz hören. Nein, Herr Tietze ist gerade im Westflügel. Und dann muss man in den Westflügel gehen, der im Osten ist, weil ich ein Rebell bin. Und dann komme ich aus einer großen Wendeltreppe mit so einem Bademantel und so einem Konjak-Schwenker. Ach, hallo, Wilhelm Dreher. Und dann begrüße ich die Leute mit so einer ausfallenden Geste. Ich hätte gern sowas wie, Herr Will spricht sie zuerst an. Herr Will will auf Spanisch angesprochen werden. Er möchte als Senior angesprochen werden. Gucken Sie ihm nicht in die Augen und sprechen Sie ihm nicht auf seine Nase an. Und auf gar keinen Fall bewerten sie seinen Bademantel, positiv
oder negativ, sagen sie einfach
nichts dazu. Wir bauen noch mal einen Kommentar
raus.
Servus, schreibt der einer.
Als ihr die Durchsage mit den
Trickdieben gemacht habt, befand ich mich am
Stuttgarter Bahnhof und hab sie für echt
gehalten. Hä? Das ist ein Scherz.
Habe dann alle
Ausländer bespuckt. Nach zwei Minuten anspucken hatte ich keine Speichelflüssigkeit mehr und wäre fast dientriert. Ihr Schweine, Lügen-Podcast. Liebe Grüße und einen sonnigen Tag. Gut, ich würde sagen, dass wir den Kommentaren lassen wir mal. Danke für die Kommentare. Vielen Dank an Titzel88. Vielen Dank. Ist das schon Identitätsdiebstahl? Wann ist Identitätsdiebstahl? Ich habe heute einen Reisepass beantragt, den kriegt ihr einen neuen. Und der hat so ganz viele neue Sicherheitsvorkehrungen. Das ist ganz geil. Und der ist auch so bunt und dann kann man mit der UV-Licht eine abgefahrene Lightshow starten eigentlich. Vergesst mal Disco. Setz euch einfach in ein dunkles Zimmer, zieht mal die Roller hinzu und nimmt den neuen Reisepass und leuchtet da mal ein bisschen rein. Das kriege ich jetzt. Freue ich mich. Heute ist der erste Tag, wo die kommen und ich habe heute einen Reisepass beantragt und den neuen Reisepass. Ich finde das so cool. Da freue ich mich mega drüber. Kann ich den mal sehen? Ich habe den da noch nicht. Ich kenne dich gar nicht so gemütlich eigentlich. Du bist immer so ein Du hast relativ viel Energie, die sich in Starrheit umwandelt bei dir. Du bist wie ein so Hunde zum Beispiel, die sind so ganz stockig. Wenn du so einen Hund hochhebst, dann biegt der sich nicht. Der ist wie so ein Brett. Eine Katze, die schlabbelt so runter. Wie so ein Helikopter. Wenn das Helikopter irgendwie so eine große Wahl nimmt. Der hängt nicht ja gerade, der schwabbelt so. Und Stefan ist auch so ein Stockmensch. Wenn du Stefan immer, wenn er irgendwie sitzen würde und du hebst ihn hoch, der würde seinen Körper nicht verändern. Der hat immer maximale Körperspannung. Du hebst ihn hoch und einfach so. Da fragen wir mal meine Sportlehrer. Bitte, was ist mit meiner Körperspannung? Ich sag mal so, eine Zwei in Sport. Das ist ja wohl, das ist wie eine Sechs in Watte. Oder hast du etwas Schlechteres als zwei in Sport? Was Schlechteres als zwei? Ja, klar. Was? Regelmässig. What? Hallo? Niemand hat es schlechter als zwei. Sprint war, ich habe nach der Hälfte der Strecke aufgehört zu rennen und bin gelaufen den Rest. Ich hatte beim Schwimmen meine Tage, konnte nicht mitmachen. Im Sprint war das glaube ich auch so.
Rack habe ich verweigert.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ein Rett ist.
Was ist denn das Rack nochmal?
Rack ist einfach diese Stahlstange.
Was sind diese beiden? Barren.
Barren, ja, und dann noch Hopfen und Malz, glaube ich.
Das sind mega kontraintuitive Worte auch.
Rack und Barren.
Ja, und dann gibt es noch das Pferd.
Ja, aber das verstehe ich, das macht noch Sinn.
Aber da haben die vorne, da dachte ich immer,
das wo die Kinder rumreiten, wenn die Kinder diese Pferd. Ja, aber das verstehe ich, das macht noch Sinn. Aber da haben die vorne, dachte ich immer, dieses, ich denke mal, das, wo die Kinder rumreiten, wenn die Kinder so diese Pferde haben, diese Besen, wo die sich immer so drauf und dann rumlaufen, wo vorne so der Pferdekopf dran ist, dachte ich mal, das haben die abgemacht von diesem Pferd. Steckenpferd! Steckenpferd, wo der Rumpf gefehlt hat. Steckenpferd? Und ich dachte immer, der Rumpf eines Steckenpferdes ist das Pferd aus der Sporthalle.
Auch an der Sporthalle finde ich auch mal so toll, dass man sich ja da Gedanken gemacht haben muss.
Ist es immer in allen Sportarten gleich, dass man von der Decke ja immer so Dinge runterrollen kann?
Die ganze Halle ist ja umsät mit so Hebeln und so Luftballons geheimen Kammers und Konfetti-Kanonen. Und dann kann man einen Hebel betätigen und dann passiert irgendwas. Eigentlich wie so ein Point-and-Click-Adventure. Aber ich finde es ganz abgefahren. Es ist in jeder Halle gleich, dass da die Ringe sind. Und wie viel habt ihr davon benutzt? Man benutzt so 20 Prozent maximal davon in so einer Sportlaufbahn, finde ich, in der Schule. Gar nichts davon benutzt. Das war immer so Next Level. Das ist, wie wenn du irgendwie in Metroid Prime durch die Gegend läufst und du siehst lauter so Türen, für die du aber eine Raketenwerfer brauchst oder so und du weißt, die kann ja nicht aufmachen, aber irgendwann komme ich da hin. Genauso war das auch immer, du siehst die Ringe an der Decke und denkst dir, wow, krass. Und ich dachte auch, die Oberstufe hängt nur an diesen Ringen rum, was nicht stimmt, die hängen irgendwie auf dem Parkplatz hoch, wer im Sport und da rief ein Bier getrunken. Wir waren manchmal ein bisschen cool, wir waren manchmal ein bisschen crazy. Ja, und bei uns gab es, das begehrteste Objekt bei uns im Sportunterricht war der Wackelpudding. Das war so eine riesengroße mannshohe Matte, wo man wie in so einem grossen Wackelpudding so eingesunken ist und so, wo sich dann glaube ich mehrere Kinder das Genick gebrochen haben, weil Matten müssen ja hart sein, also moderne Sportmann sind ja hart, damit man nicht, wenn man auftritt, umknickt und so.
Und ich kann auch nicht mehr, es gibt irgendwie so zwei Anfragen von Sportlehrern, habe ich auch schon mal erzählt, aber so diese SS-Lehrer, SS-Sportlehrer.
Die harten Matten und die weichen Matten.
Ja, genau, im Grunde, ja. Aber auch wo dann irgendwie einer dieser SS-Lehrer dann irgendwie springt, jemand irgendwie über so einen 50 Meter hohen brennenden Ölfass, fällt er runter, fällt hart auf sein Bein,
fängt an zu schreien und also fragt er hat sich das Bein gebrochen, Bein gebrochen, alles strömt zu ihm
und der Lehrer nur so, wenn er sich sein Bein gebrochen
hätte, würde er ganz anders schreien.
Dann würde er nicht mehr schreien. Und nur so,
wir helfen ihm trotzdem
oder passiert jetzt gar nichts
mehr.
Beim Schwimmunterricht habe ich irgendwann
gesagt, jetzt ist es vorbei.
Ich bin kein Fisch, das ist nichts für mich. Irgendwann habe ich erst mal mehr ausgedacht zu haben, wirklich. Und dann habe ich irgendwann, ich habe eine Trichterbrust. Habe ich schon mal von meiner Trichterbrust eigentlich erzählt? Das ist wirklich, wenn du gerade aus dem letzten Prototyp, du hast den Fehlkauf von Stefan fast abgewimmelt und jetzt kommt der Trichterbrust Stefan. Trichterbrust Stefan? Habe ich mir davon erzählt? Meine Brust geht
so ein bisschen vorne rein. So ein bisschen tatsächlich.
Das ist nicht so schlimm, ey.
Das ist nicht so schlimm, das haben viele Leute.
Das haben viele Leute. Und dann habe ich irgendwann
mal im Sportunterricht einfach gesagt, ich behaupte,
das würde mir im Wege stehen. Und habe gesagt,
habe die Lüge aufgestellt, das beeinträchtigt
mein Lungenvolumen. Und deswegen habe ich eine bessere Note
bekommen, als ich eigentlich gehabt hätte.
Weil ich behauptet hätte, ich habe weniger Konditionen dadurch.
Was absolut erlogen ist.
Aber die Lüge aufgestellt, das beeinträchtigt mein Lungenvolumen. Und deswegen habe ich eine bessere Note bekommen, als ich eigentlich gehabt hätte, weil ich behauptet hätte,
ich habe weniger Konditionen dadurch, was absolut erlogen ist. Aber ich habe mich so
durchs Leben gefakt einfach mit sowas, mit Behauptungen.
Das ist eigentlich einfach
mega praktisch. Ich kann auf dem Sofa liegen,
kann da so ein bisschen Cola reinmachen,
dann hohe ich dann, Gott, das ist nicht so schlimm,
das geht auch nicht so toll. Mir wird wirklich Körper nicht schlecht,
wenn ich das höre.
Das ist mega beleidigend. Ich glaube, das ist der schlimmste Punkt in meinem Körper, den man berühren kann oder den man drücken kann, ist neben dem Bauchnabel das Zwerchfell. So zwischen dem Rippenkorb. Aber ich finde auch gut, wenn deine Mutter dir sagt, ich habe Krebs und du einfach sagst, mir wird körperlich schlecht, wenn ich das höre. Der Opa ist jetzt gestorben. Erzähl mir das so nicht, während ich esse, Mutter. Gott, lass mich das mal aufessen, zünn den Nachtisch noch ein und dann. Weißt du, das ist echt, ich erzähle gerade von meinen körperlichen Schwachstellen. Ja, das ist aber echt schwach. Ach, eisse. Ja, das ist doch Quatsch. Was ist denn Quatsch? Das ist doch echt Quatsch. Aber ein Kind bei uns in der Schule hatte das auch, der hat
so eine, ich glaube,
das hieß, glaube ich, tatsächlich Spatzenbrust.
Spatzenbrust, das ist anscheinend so eine
medizinische Verfassung. Hühnerbrust.
Hühnerbrust! Das geht raus.
Die ist das Gegenteil davon.
Du hast doch einen Schaden, lass doch mal den Scheiß, wo er bleiben soll.
Wir gleichen uns aus.
Wenn jemand die Trichterbrust und
Hühnerbrust sich umarmen, dann verschwinden sie. Und dann können sie alle drumherum was wünschen. Dann entsteht Antimaterie. Das war tatsächlich so im Kindergarten. Tatsächlich hat man als Kind teilweise ganz merkwürdige Vorstellungen von Sexualität und wie Sex abläuft. Weil wenn du es noch nicht weißt, dann denkst du dir das teilweise selber aus. Ja, ich weiß, ich denke mir bis heute.
Und bei uns, ich hatte tatsächlich immer die Vorstellung, weil bei uns war irgendwann so das, im Kindergarten, also wirklich frühkindiges Alter, so der gefühlte Begriff für Penis und Vagina war Schlüssel und Schlüsselloch.
So impliziert ja schon, dass man das ineinander stecken kann, aber ich habe es ein bisschen zu wörtlich genommen und ich dachte tatsächlich... Bei uns war es lustigerweise Schwängel und Fotze. Süss, Kinder, Möse, feuchte Möse und harter Schwängel war es bei uns. Und dann tatsächlich hat sich bei mir als Kind in meinem kindlichen Bewusstsein dann die Idee eingeprägt, dass auch jeder Penis nur in jeweils eine Vagina passt. dass es wie Schlüssel und Schlüsselloch ist, dass der Penis wie ein Schlüssel ist und nur in eine eigene. Man muss sich finden. So ein romantischer Abend und dann leider, ups, wir passen nicht zusammen. Aber das war tatsächlich bei mir die kindige Vorstellung, das gibt total Sinn. Bei mir war es so, ich habe, kennst du, es war immer das Leben, dass du diese grossartige Serie. Die Fickshow. Das erste Mal masturbiert habe ich. Ja was halt in den Körpern stattfindet, mit den weichen Blutkörperchen, den roten Blutkörperchen. Den gelben, über die man selten springt, die ein bisschen unters Raster fallen. Die schwarzen Blutkörperchen, wow, wow, wow, wow. Und dann gab es halt diese Anfangsszene, dieses lebendes Leben, es ist schön, so wunderschön. Und da haben sich ein Mann und eine Frau liebgehabt. Nackt. Genau, nackt liebgehabt. Und dann sind die in den Himmel geflogen. Und das war meine Vorstellung. Lange Zeit, weil es misleading ist, Leute. Und denkt euch mal, macht euch mal ein bisschen mehr Gedanken. Es war Art, glaube ich, in ZDF, die diese Show gemacht haben. Denkt doch mal ein bisschen weiter. Ich dachte mein Leben lang, nein, das wird nicht passieren, ich fliege in den Himmel. Ja, vor allem gerade so eine Aufklärungs- oder Wissenschaftssendung sollte doch da besonderen Augenmerk drauflegen, dass wenn die für Kinder ist, dass du denen gerade was Sexualität angehst, keinen Scheiss erzählst, weil das ist toxisch. Zeig ein Schlafzimmer, was unaufgeräumt ist, wo der Fernseher noch läuft, dann hat der Mann auch die Hose an, so die Frau hat noch das Kind im Arm. Zeig mal, wie Sex wirklich ist. Zeig so einen Typen, der mit Socken in die nächste Tanke geht, um Kondome zu holen. Das kannst du zeigen. Der besoffen nach Hause kommt, wenn eine Frau bewusstlos im Bett liegt und dann da so noch halb vergewaltigt, halb zustimmt, man weiß es nicht mehr. Es ist schon sexual abusive.
Keine Ahnung, aber das ist das echte Leben.
Oder einfach so eine, nee, lass heute nicht, bitte.
Das schöne Leben.
Es ist schön.
Lektion fünf, Sexualität.
Nee, irgendwie geht es heute nicht gut.
Es war ja, es war einmal das Leben.
Das ist mal, es ist das Leben.
So ist das Leben, machen wir jetzt mal. Das ist eine neue Sendung. Wir zeigen mal, wie es wirklich ist. Das finde ich nicht schlecht. Auch, dass die Blutkörperchen gar nicht mehr existieren, so normale Verdauung findet nicht mehr statt. Forget it. Das war es war einmal das Leben. Mittlerweile ist es ganz anders. So wie ich das über den lebenden Körper machen. Nee, nee, nee, das ist total interessant, wie Sterben der Körper funktioniert. Oder man zeigt es einfach, Sexualität gar nicht, aber nicht so ein Scheiß, da bin ich auf jeden Fall... Gab es doch mal Aids dann, es war immer das Leben? Ich glaube, das gab es damals noch nicht. Aber sind Aids in deren Welt nicht so ein Superheld, der einfach ein unbesiegbarer Superheld? Ja, das stimmt schon. Superman einfach, ein böser Superman. In der Welt, klar, die Antikörperchen waren immer die kleinen mit den Pistolen und die sind dann mal angelaufen. Und Krebs ist wie so eine coole Gruppe, wo alle dazugehören wollen, so, hast du Bock, mitzumachen? Ja, klar, klar, cool. Dann kommen die Zähne und fangen die an zu rauchen, die Zähne, verstehst du? Dann kommt die Chemotherapie und dann macht die die fertig und so. Macht aber auch ein paar eigene Zähne fertig, aber das war kraftbar, alles klar. Und dann vertragen sich alle, aber Aids sind Superhelden. Aids sind unbesiegbaren Superhelden. Das ist eine grausame Folge, glaube ich, aber ich freue mich. Staffelfinale. Woher will man wissen, dass Zählen nicht genauso ein Bewusstsein haben wie wir? Dass da irgendwie was für uns der Zweite Weltkrieg ist, ist für die halt eine Krebserkrankung. So wo halt dann irgendwie Leute um sich greifen und alle denken so Ja, Krebs, Krebs, du machst das Land besser und dann irgendwann so, oh shit, was ist denn jetzt gerade, was geht denn jetzt? Und dann kommt irgendwie die Chemotherapie und ballert alle weg und so. Die Chemotherapie ist wie Amerika so eigentlich, ist dann am Ende eingegriffen, hat dann entkrebsifiziert. Genau, und alle so, wie konnten wir nur das wählen, das war echt schweißig. Dann gab es die großen Nasenberger Prozesse und dann wurde da erstmal ausgesiebt. Hat jetzt nicht so gut funktioniert, das Wortspiel. Ich weiß, deine runden Augen gucken mich traurig an. Die Creme de la Creme. Ja.
Ach ja, was soll ich noch sagen?
Ja, was wollt ihr denn?
Spaß bei Seite, Leute.
Komm, Spaß bei Seite.
Nehmen wir noch auf?
Warte, ich habe keine Taschen-Tüche mehr.
Warte.
Stimmt, wir können nicht mehr.
Halt mal kurz an, einfach.
Ich finde auch, Wissen macht manchmal einen kaputt. Ich habe mal irgendwann gehört, dass wenn man niest, das drei Meter lang fliegt, drei Meter weit fliegt. Und seitdem, immer wenn Menschen niesen in meiner Umgebung, gehe ich in diesen drei Meter Radius. Hör auf zu niesen, ey, komm. Nee, komm. Nee. Wir haben ja letztens mal über Powerbanks und Akkus geredet und wussten nicht, wie Akkus funktionieren. Und da haben wir dann länger Einsendungen bekommen von Leuten, die... Das habe ich jetzt... So, jetzt erzählst du... Ja, lies mal vor und sag mir danach mal, ob es quatscht oder nicht. Also, jemand hat versucht, Holgrich, hat dankenswerterweise versucht, uns zu erklären, wie ein Akku, ein Wiederauflades funktioniert. Und er hat geschrieben, that anmoderation. Du bist halt echt, du bist halt echt on point. Einen Akku. Also, er schreibt, pass auf, einen Akku könnt ihr euch wie einen Raum voller kleiner Zwerge vorstellen. Nicht nur Zwerge, sondern kleinen Zwerge. Ja, die kleinen. Kleiner Zwerge vorstellen. Kinderzwerge. Kinderzwerge siegt nicht wie kein kleiner als richtige Zwerge. Größer, glaube ich. Die werden immer größer. Wenn der Akku geladen wird, werden alle Zwerge auf eine Seite des Raums geschubst. Von wem? Wenn der Akku dann genutzt wird, laufen einzelne Zwerge langsam auf die andere Seite des Raums. Ich nehme mir so vor, wie die so sich langsam, das ist so der Zwergenaufstand, die sind so langsam sauer auf diejenigen, die sie schubsen, und dann laufen sie langsam wieder los. Da sie beim Laufen ganz stark mit den Armen wirbeln, entsteht ein Luftstrom, der eine Turbine betreibt, die wiederum Strom erzeugt, mit dem wiederum der Akku aufgeladen wird. Es wird zu kompliziert. Und dann springen wir in die Geschichte. Darin, wie wird Strom erzeugt? Naja, stellt euch gleich den Zwerge vor. Ab und zu wird ein Zwerg in die Turbine gezogen. Oh nein! Deshalb verringert sich über die Zeit die Kapazität des Akkus verringert. Okay, cool. Danke, weißt du, wie wir gerade sind? Wir sind so, wenn der Lehrer, der coole Lehrer ein anschauliches
Beispiel findet und wir so, haha,
ja, was passiert da mit den Zwergen, ne?
Und wo ist Legolas?
Und dann mit so einem
selbstgebauten Pfeil, so einem
Pfeilgift-Vorrichtung, so ein Pff, dann
irgendwie ein Mischeele abspucken. Das sind wir
gerade. Ja, sorry. Nee, Holgerich,
vielen Dank. Also,
der Strom ist im Akku und der wird auf eine andere Seite geliefert und dann fließe wieder zurück. Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen. Also, was meinst du in deinem Beispiel mit Zwergen? Was meinst du in deinem Beispiel mit die Wirbel mit den Armen? Was meinst du im Beispiel mit Strom? Im Ernst, wenn die Strom erzeugen, wie erzeugen, der Strom kommt auch da rein. Kannst du das nochmal vereinfacht darstellen? Kannst du das Beispiel nochmal vereinfachen? Ich glaube, er beschreibt einfach die beiden Vorgänge. Einmal den Ladevorgang, alle Zwerge kommen auf einer Seite des Raumes und dann, wenn du den Strom verwenden willst, wenn du die Batterie irgendwo einlegst, in dein Gameboy zum Beispiel, mit dem du so gerne Tetris spielst, dann laufen die Zwerge einzeln. Ich fühl mich angesprochen, weil er hat meine popkulturellen Referenzen getroffen. Vielleicht wäre es besser zu sagen, die Zwerge werden alle auf so einen Berg geschoben und dann hängen die alle auf dem Berg und dann, wenn man dann die Klappe aufmacht, rollen die Zwerge alle einzeln wieder runter, den Hügel runter und da kann man dann wie so ein Wasserrad an die Zwerge bauen, wo die dann das Wasserrad betrieben wird. Herr Meier, Herr Meier, Herr Meier, eine Wortmeldung, eine Wortmeldung.
Klaus, ja.
Stehen die Anzahl der Zwerge, steht das für die Zahl des Akkus, was man dann bei Amazon findet?
Da steht dann immer 2400 MHA oder sowas.
Ist das die Anzahl der Zwerge da drin, Herr Mayer? Ja. Haben Sie schon die Arbeit korrigiert? Irgendwann mal wusste ich auch, wie man sich Strom... Irgendwann wusste es auch mal, wie man Heuerspiele macht. Wie man Podcast macht. Wie man Strom was? Was der Unterschied zwischen Stromstärke und Spannung ist. Ja. Jetzt begeben wir uns auf Terrain, wo der eine Nutzer wäre mit der Augen. Ich würde gerne ein Bild präsentieren. Das meint der Typ aber mit, das meint der Typ, wie viel, das meint der Typ. Nee, ja, das ist mir doch scheißegal, was der meint. Das meint der Typ mit, wir begeben uns mit Wissen aus, was andere schon längst haben. Denkst du jetzt, wir erfinden gerade Stromspannung oder was? Aber viele Leute haben da vielleicht keine konkrete Vorstellung. Ich stelle es mir vor wie einen Fluss, wie den Rhein. Dann, es gibt Flüsse, die sehen, also stell dir vor, du überprüfst, wie viel Liter Wasser fliessen sekündlich durch den Fluss. Also du stellst dich an den Rand des Rheins und guckst dann, wie viel Liter Wasser flit pro Sekunde hier gerade an mir vorbei, im Fluss. Das ist die Stromstärke. Wie viel Liter Wasser pro Sekunde durch den Strom, durch den Fluss fließt. Die Spannung ist die Geschwindigkeit des Wassers. Aber das hängt ja miteinander zusammen. Oder dann der Druck sozusagen.
Du kannst ja einen grossen Fluss haben, der ganz langsam fließt. Die Spannung ist der Bus, der auf einer Brücke über den Rhein fährt.
Ja.
Die Anzahl des übrig gebliebenen Benzins im Tank des Busses.
Und wenn dich dann Olli Dietrich retweetet, dann ist das der Widerstand sozusagen.
Ich glaube, das stimmt so und wenn nicht, ist mir auch scheißegal.
So, tschüss.
Wir sind ja nicht durch. Wie lange hältst du mich in diesem Raum noch fest? Wir sind seit zwei Tagen in diesem Raum. Du hast die Tür abgeschlossen. Was müssen wir denn noch machen? Du willst mich melken?
Entschuldigung.
Komm, ich kenne die Zähne.
Zwanni. Zwickel. Laura, melde dich bitte für deine App-Idee, Netflinster. Melde dich, dann kriegst du ein Zwanni. Netflix. Ja, das war Podcast-Ufo für diese Woche. Wie lange haben wir denn aufgenommen? 45. Was? 46. Mehr war. Doch ja aufgenommen. Nee, 46. Na gut, dann machen wir noch ein bisschen. Nö. Dann machen wir noch Fun. Doch, wir haben noch Spaß. Ich habe noch ein paar Sonde aufgeschrieben. Okay. Hör mal, das ist gut. Stell mal, wer fällt das vor? So nach der Stunde so, hören wir auf, oder? Nö, komm, wir müssen noch ein bisschen machen. Die Sendung ist ja nicht mal ansatzweise. Nö, komm. Nee, tatsächlich habe ich neulich mal wieder Fernsehen geguckt. Fahre nochmal an. Tatsächlich habe ich neulich mal wieder Fernsehen geguckt. Aha. Und ich habe rumgesappt. Und man muss sagen, also aus diesem Standpunkt, Fernsehen ist mittlerweile sehr absurd einfach nur noch. Weil ich bin auf so einen Privatsender gelandet, es war nachmittags, Sonntag war das, und dann plötzlich habe ich bunte Burger, der Laden bei uns auf der Ecke zur Arbeit, war im Fernsehen. Und zwar, ich weiß nicht, bis heute nicht, ob es gefankt war, aber wahrscheinlich schon. Und zwar so eine Polizeisendung, so eine Aufstreife, Wache und so Sendung, wo dann Polizisten, wo man Polizisten zuguckt, wie die auf Streife sind. Und dann kamen bunte Burger plötzlich und ich denke mir, what, da essen wir manchmal? Und dann wurden da Leute vergiftet, weil der Kellner war der Freund, der Ex-Freund einer Besucherin bei bunte Burger, das ist ein veganer Burgerland, und dann haben die da gegessen mit der Familie und der hat den Pilze, Magic Mushrooms, ins Essen gemacht und dann sind die da rumgelaufen und diese Folge fing so an, ich dachte mir, wow, bunte Burger ist im Fernsehen. Da kommen zwei Polizisten rein und dann sind wir so ein Leinen, ganz viele Leinen-Schauspieler, die lachend in diesem Laden herumlaufen. Ich dachte mir, wow, Fernsehen ist geil geworden in der letzten Zeit, wo ich Netflix geguckt habe und Amazon Prime. Warum habe ich das geguckt? Das ist viel geiler. Und dann laufen da plötzlich so wilde Leinen durchspielt der Stelle herum, haben sich kaputt gelacht, aber offensichtlich war das der hundertste Take und die hat nicht mehr so richtig Bock darauf zu lachen. Und dann kam raus, dass der Ex-Freund die Familie mit Magic Mushrooms vergiftet hat. Und dann kam ein Notarzt und dann hat er die mitgenommen und dann war die Folge vorbei, weil die sich das gelöst haben. Das ist Fernsehen mittlerweile, aber auch in unserem Laden hier. Aber warum macht man das denn? Es ist ja wirklich tolle Negativ-PR. Oder wissen die einfach, dass vegane Leute nicht diese Sendungen schauen oder dass die da keine Zielgruppenüberschreitungen haben? Ich weiß es nicht. Das ist ja auch strange. Wir brauchen eine Restaurant, in dem jemand umgebracht wird. Ich finde geil, dass sie trotzdem trotzdem vegan vergiftet wurden. Ja. Na gut, auf der anderen Seite, wie willst du auch nicht vegan jemanden vergiften? Kannst du Fleisch vergiften? Ich meine jetzt das Gift, das Gift war ja auch vegan. Das war halt Mushrooms. Das ist der Salat der Drogen eigentlich. Ist das so, dass die gesundheitsbewussten Drogen-Junkies dann Mushrooms nehmen und nicht das Chemiezeug? Ja, klar. Das ist schon abgefahren. Diese Drogenwelt ist gerade schon abgefahren. Warst du mal in der Nähe zumindest von der Drogenwelt? Ich glaube, ich war mal auf einer Party, wo man ein schönes Ganja-Geschoss durch die Gegend gereicht wurde. Aber mehr als das auch nicht, ne? Wahrscheinlich. Hey, hey, hey, manchmal, da geht dann so ein, du weißt, wenn ich meine, geht dann schon mal irgendwie, zieht sich zurück und kommt dann rum und streicht sich über die Nase und nickt mir zu und ich denke mir so, brauchst du ein Taschentuch und... Wow, Nazi-Wien. Geil. Ja. Ich glaube, die krasseste Abhängigkeit, die ich hatte, war Nasenspray jemals.
Du warst abhängig von Nasenspray?
Ja, doch. Auf jeden Fall.
Aber wo hast du dir das hingesprüht?
Irgendwann habe ich nur Intravenös einfach eingeführt mit so einer Gruppe Spritze.
Das ist doch mal ein Sketch für deine Scheiss-Sketch-Comedy-Show.
Da machst du so einen Prank, gehst du zum Apotheker und sagst, ein Nasenspray bitte, Dann sagt er ja hier, dann nimmt er das und spritzt sich das so in die Armbeuge ins Handgelenk. Jetzt geht's wieder und geht. Prank, die Comedy-Show. Das verdutzte Gesicht der Verkäuferin. Ha, ha, ha. Danach erschrecken wir alte Menschen auf der Straße mit dem Hitler-Kostüm. Buh! Ich bin immer noch da. Die einfallsloseste Show der Welt. Buh! Alte Leute schreien. Umschubsen. Mit so Knallteufeln, die man denen so vor die Füsse wirft. So Knallerbsen, die auch nicht so richtig laut sind. Ein bisschen nur. Das finde ich auch so. Silvester haben wir, ich war in einem wilden Freundeskreis und da haben die halt alle diese Polenböller gestartet und es gab Detonationen. Es war unfassbar, dass man sagen musste, dass die Regel war, dass jemand Alarm rufen musste, bevor er diesen Böller geworfen hat. Also abstrus laut. Also wir mussten wirklich haben gerufen, Achtung! Und dann ist es wirklich explodiert, es war unmenschlich laut. Und dann war aber ein Freund dabei, und das ist glaube ich immer, der diese kleinen Knallerbs dabei hatte, immer so geworfen hat. Wütend auch. Und dann explodiert die auch nicht immer, nur so hier das Dritte. Man kann die aber auch nicht wütend wegwerfen. Scheiße, ich hasse diese Knallerbs. Weil der Effekt hat. Aber ist das ein Filmding, dieser Move, wenn Magier verschwinden,
dieses auf den Boden werfen,
diese Rauchbombe, dann kommt diese Säule aus Rauch
und dann kann man wegrennen.
Ist das so ein Filmmyth oder geht das weg?
Das geht.
Das wäre auch mal ein guter Gag für ein Real Life.
Das ist ein Büro und dann geht der Rauchmelder an oder sowas.
Da sieht man auch die Fenster aufmachen.
Die zehn Minuten danach sieht man halt auch nie.
Aber das wäre schon cool. So ein cooler Move eigentlich. Kann das mal jemand prüfen? Holgeri, check das mal. Und erklär mal mit der lustigen Zwergenmetapher, wie das eigentlich funktioniert. Oh, mehr Zwergenmetapher. Aber das war die echt eine berechtigte Frage. Also diese ganze Gimli-Storyline, die ist ja auch so ein bisschen Comic-Relief eigentlich, der sagt ja dann auch mit, der sagt ja auch, dass Zwergenfrauen so ähnlich aussehen wie die und so dann macht Aragon, der Joke-Star Aragon, wegen dem Bart, Riesenlacher, immer wieder, aber wie sehen denn Zwergenfrauen aus, warum sieht man die Zwergenfrauen und sind die grösser als Frauen, als die Männer, wie sehen Zwergenkinder aus, man sieht auch die Zwergenkinder, kommen die mit einem Bart auf die Welt, sehen die auch schon so aus, ich finde das alles faszinierend, auch Orks, auch dieses, wo Saruman dann diese Uruk-Heis züchtet, wo der so Menschen mit Orks kreuzt und dann diese Hand auf den Kopf macht.
Ruhig heiß.
Die werden aus der Wand gezogen.
Alles klar, Tolkien, da bist du mir ein bisschen zu weit gegangen.
Warum?
Ich denke, da gibt es keine Weibchen eigentlich.
Die werden einfach so gebrütet für den Kampf.
Und es wurden ja auch nur ... Wie kann man denn kreuzen mit Menschen?
Ja, das ist halt Magie.
Das ist sowieso Zaubermagie.
Also der hat die damit ja gekreuzt. Filmfehler. Habe ich früher bei Filmfehler eingeschrieben. Nee, das ist eben kein Filmfehler ist sowieso Zaubermagie, also der hat die damit ja gekreuzigt.
Filmfehler, da habe ich früher bei Filmfehler eingeschrieben, es gibt keine grossen Adler. Aber ich habe mich mal gefragt, kann es sein, dass Herr der Ringe in einer Welt, dass es einfach sehr kleine Menschen sind? Die Adler normalgrösser. Ja genau, dass die Adler normalgrösser sind, die Elefanten sind absurd gross, das ist einfach eine wahnsinnig kleine Welt, so eine Modellwelt. Und wenn wir, wenn man da wäre, wenn man auf Mittelerde wäre, wären das einfach alles wahnsinnig so kleine Menschen, die rumlaufen. Und die Elefanten wären normal gross. Ja, und die laufen auch so viel, die laufen immer ewig lang, weil die einfach ewig lang brauchen, um irgendwo hinzukommen. Die Karte ist aber nicht so gross. Ja, das stimmt. Und Mordor ist auch nicht so gross. Und die Adler sind so absurd gross, diese Drachen und die Elefanten. Deswegen habe ich mir kurz gedacht, vielleicht sind die einfach nur so klein alle. Ja, das kann schon sein. Und dann plötzlich verliert das alles so an Spannung, weil man denkt, kleine Menschen zählen nicht. Auch Trolle oder so, das sind halt dann einfach so normal große Leute. Nicht mittelgrosse Menschen. Ja, das sind dann große Zwerge, muss ich sagen. Ja, geil. Das ist eine geile Welt, in die du mich hier entführst, in die immer die Gedankenwelt. Geil. Das ist richtig geil. Mal sowas wie Tolkien schreiben, einfach so, wo sich dann irgendwelche Trottel in einem Podcast drüber unterhalten, wie könnte das sein, wo man sagt, hier ist eine Sprache, hier ist so eine Landkarte. Aber kann man jetzt auch nicht mehr machen, weil jetzt sagt man, ja, ist ja geklaut von Tolkien. Wir haben ja viel vor mit unserem Leben und wir wollen auch noch mal irgendwann seriösen Scheiß machen und wir wollen auch mal irgendwann vielleicht Fiktion erzählen, wir wollen ernst nehmen, Sachen machen. Glaubst du, man kann uns irgendwann mal ernst nehmen oder glaubst du, rückwirk, ganz im Ernst, das war nicht ganz ernst, da will ich mit zu kämpfen, denkst du, angenommen damals gab es schon Podcasts oder sowas, glaubst du, David Lynch hätte einen Podcast gemacht und dann hätte man oder so ein Stanley Kubrick, wo man dann nachher dem so einen Genie unterstellt, wenn man seine Filme sieht, wo man die auch nicht ganz entschlüsseln kann und es einfach Kunstwerke sind, die man selber interpretieren will. Aber wie man, hat man dann das Gefühl, hätte der jemals einen Podcast gemacht, wo der einfach alles offenlegt und auch seine Unzulänglichkeiten offenlegt? Weil wir stellen unsere Unzulänglichkeiten zur Schau. Wir sind wie so Exhibitionisten. Ja, vielleicht hätte der das auf eine andere kondensierte Art gemacht mit seinen Filmen, dass er gerade weil er es nicht dadurch ausdrücken konnte, dann halt alle Emotionilitäten in die Filme gepackt hat. Wohingegen wir, wir sind halt leer den ganzen Tag, wir sind den ganzen Tag leer, weil wir alle schon rausballern auf verschiedenen Ventilen und dann am Ende haben wir nichts mehr und müssen dann irgendeinen Schwachsinn uns ausdenken und können vielleicht auch nur Comedy machen, so einen schlechten Gag oder sowas, aber mal so eine ernste, tiefe Geschichte, ich weiß es nicht, aber ich finde auf jeden Fall gut, die in der Stefan-Tietze-Autobiografie sollte auf jeden Fall mit dem Satz beginnen, kann man mich irgendwann mal ernst nehmen, Stefan-Tietze 2017, und wir wissen alle heute, die Antwort lautet, jein. Lautet, und dann Teil zwei ab März im Handel. Das ist der große Cliffhanger. Ich will meine Autobiografie so mit einem Cliffhanger enden. Doch dann. Ich will, dass du meine Biografie schreibst und ich deine Biografie. Ich will es vernichten, das wird vernichten sein. Ich glaube schon. Gibt es eigentlich auch Leute, die Biografien über Leute geschrieben haben, die die nicht mögen?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Echt, weil sonst ist ja immer so ein ja irgendwie toller Typ und cool und wie leidenschaftlich der bla bla bla.
Aber das war ein richtiges Arschloch. Kindheit, Scheiße, Stuhle, Scheiße, danach nur schlechte Musik gemacht.
Das ist nur das erste Kapitel.
Can't buy me love, was soll das für Scheiße sein?
Das ist nur das Vorwort.
Wir beginnen das erste Kapitel, aber fangen wir von vorne an. So, jetzt mal ganz kurz Ruhe hier. Jetzt will ich mal kurz was sagen. Wie der schon geboren wurde. In tollen Verhältnissen. Wow, sympathischer Kerl. So mit Augenrollen. Ich will doch gerne so ein Buch ansprechen, das so geschrieben ist, als müsste man es ständig gegen laute Leute verteidigen. So, jetzt mal Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, ganz kurz mal. Eine Sache mal, ich will nur eins ganz kurz sagen. Auf den ersten acht Seiten haben sie Leute geschrieben, in Caps, ein Großteil ist in Caps geschrieben. Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, mach die Musik, mach die, kurz leise, ruh, ruh, ruh, kurz die Musik.
Das war das Hörbuch zum Buch Mein Leben, der Lärm und ich von Florentin Will.
Ah, schon gut.
Hier sind eigene Gangskommande.
Schon gut, schon echt gut, schon wirklich delivered.
Und auch so mittendrin im Buch so, sorry, ich kann gerade nicht, kannst du du ganz, ich ganz kurz, sorry, kannst du die Tür bitte? Kannst du kurz die Tür? Ein Telefonat. Sorry, ganz kurz, ich schreibe gerade das Buch. Kann ich dich ganz kurz zurück? Was? Die Oma? Kannst du vielleicht Spinat den feinen? Nein, einfach den schon mal vorwerfen. Wenn du einfach kurz in deinem Mikrofon, ich bin auch gleich da. Ich schreibe ganz kurz noch weiter. Bestes Story von Lars Pauls war, er hat gerade ein Video geschnitten und hatte da irgendwie so ein bisschen, ich sag mal so halb privat, halb berufliche Probleme irgendwie. Er hat so ein paar heiße Briefe bekommen, sag ich mal, von Behörden und die absolut nicht für die Öffentlichkeit waren und die er bearbeiten musste und da waren auch Anwälte im Gespräch und blablabla und er hat währenddessen gerade sein Video geschnitten und er hat anscheinend eines dieser extrem persönlichen Dokumente wollte irgendwo hinziehen und hat es aus Versehen in sein Video gezogen und es war dann als Standbild im Video und er hat es dann nicht mehr angeguckt, er hat es gerendert, rausgerechnet und hochgeladen und dann hat er sich gewundert, dass bei dem Video immer so, ja ist jaig, aber Minute acht, vierundzwanzig und er ist angeguckt und er moderiert und mitten im Satz kommt so irgendwie, wie so Steuerbescheidsmahnung, Lars Paulsen, einfach wirklich so für zehn Sekunden steht das Bild drin und ist dann wieder weg und also okay, einfach so mittendrin, aber ich finde das auch so lustig, dass das, was niemand wissen darf, er genau in das Video zieht, dass er alle wissen sollen. Das ist völlig falsch, einfach worst possible place. So ein kleiner Fehler, der maximale Auswirkungen hat. Vor allem das Video war schon eine halbe Stunde online und dann haben die Leute das erste viele haben das einfach gedacht, okay, checke ich jetzt nicht ganz den Gag, aber auch so völlig unmoderiert. Das ist das Beste an Comedy, und deswegen machen wir das auch, machen wir uns nichts vor. Wenn wir irgendwann einen Fehler haben, einen Ausrutscher, der wird verziehen, weil der als nicht verstandener Gag. Man kann Schwächen als Genialität verkaufen. Apropos Schwäche, ich habe noch nicht auch Briefe von Behörden bekommen, und zwar habe ich, meine Parksituation generell in Köln ist die furchtbar, bei mir in der Straße ist sie komplett verloren. Und dann irgendwann, nach zehn Minuten Parkplatzsuche, sagst du einfach, fuck it, parke ich mal alle Verbot und stelle den Wagen morgen um. So, morgens sind die ganze Leute zur Arbeit, da ist immer die Straße frei, abends ist sie immer voll. Und dann habe ich das aber vergessen, das Auto da zu stehen, umzuparken. Und dann bin ich, als ich Freitags mein Auto geholt habe, und dann ich mir, fuck, ich habe die ganze Woche habe ich mein Auto im Parkverbot stehen lassen. Und dann kam, dachte ich mir, ja, die können mir jetzt doch nicht für jeden Tag einen Brief schicken. Die können mir jetzt nicht für jeden Tag ein Knöllchen schicken. Augenscheinlich doch. Und dann kam erst einer, am nächsten Tag kam noch ein zweiter, dann kam ein dritter. Und der vierte Brief, der kam, vom vierten Tag war nicht nur im Parkverbot, sondern auch auf dem Gehweg geparkt. Da dachte ich mir, Moment mal, das kann aber nicht sein. Entweder wurde mein Auto verschoben von Donnerstag auf Freitag auf den Gehweg, oder die wollen mich komplett ins Abseits schießen, aber das ist doch scheiße. Und dann dachte ich mir erst, das könnte ich jetzt anfechten. Aber habe ich es nicht gemacht, waren fünf Euro, das ist doch scheissegal. Aber das ist doch scheiße. Dann jubeln die einem so einen Fehler unter. Das ist immer mehr so, Mord, Betrug, alles dabei so, wow, wow, wow, wow, Leute. Nee, nee, das wäre nicht mein Aldo, mein Aldo wäre ja, komm. Im Privaten wird auf den Tisch gehauen natürlich wieder, aber dann bei der Behörde, klein beigeben. Das ist Stefan Tietze für mich. Nee, aber auch hier, auch hier denke ich mir so, brauche ich auch eine Referenz, jemand, der mir sagt, boah, das können die nicht machen, auch für fünf Euro, das können die nicht machen, kannst du ganz einfach zurückschicken und dann machen die das nicht. Habe ich niemanden, also mache ich das, bezahre ich es einfach. Ja. Auch sowas wie, was, und dann hat die dich nicht mehr zurückgerufen? Wie kann die das machen? Und ich so, ja man, mega scheiße, das was fehlt ja, ja stimmt, total, ah, ah, ich rette mich dann auch. Großteil privat, was, was, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Zug überfahren worden.
Hä?
So, ich habe gar nicht zugehört.
So, ich habe gerade dieses Buch, diesen lustigen Artikel gelesen, über diese Familie, die überfahren wurde.
Ich habe gerade noch über meinen eigenen Witz gelacht von vor zwei Tagen.
Der mit der Familie, die überfahren wurde? Du weißt schon.
Can't buy me love.
Can't buy me love? Can't buy me love. Naja, der Mann übernimmt sie mich auch. You can buy me love. Du kannst es nicht mehr so, dass es nicht mehr so, dass es nicht mehr so, dass es nicht Rätsel der Natur bis heute. Es gibt so ein paar Rätseln, Stonehenge, Concord, warum schützt sich Concorde ab, weil sie mir eingefallen haben, ich glaube, es ist relativ einfach zu lösen. Was ist ein C? Niemand weiß es. Jeff, Fragezeichen, keine Ahnung. Nein, Florentin hat neulich Süßkartoffeln gegessen, nichts einfacher als das, Süßkartoffeln zu essen. Süßkartoffeln und Pommes, ja. Süßkartoffeln und Pommes, genau. Aber danach war dein Mundraum, Rachenraum, Lippen, schwarz, Pech, schwarz.
Ich habe das in meinem Leben noch nicht gesehen, Leute haben mich angesprochen, wir sind ja alle große Prankster, du hast es erst nicht geglaubt, wir haben alle herzlich gelacht, aber dann bist du zum Spiegel gegangen und hast gesehen, du hast einfach schwarzen Prank. Ja, vor allem meine Kollegin hat auch Süßkartoffelpommes gegessen und bei ihr war nichts zu sehen.
Und ich kann mir das rückwirkend nur so erklären, dass in der Fritteuse vielleicht irgendwie irgendwas drin war, was dann irgendwie verkohlt ist oder so. Aber ich habe nichts geschmeckt, nichts Abnormales. Oder meine Geschmacksnähte sind einfach so über den Jordan, dass ich einfach irgendwie Erde essen könnte und so. Und ich glaube, da war vielleicht ein Stück Kohle oder so. Und hatte ich Kohle immer, ich kann es mir nicht erklären, was das war, es war ganz merkwürdig. Ja, so ein Pech schwarz wirklich, ganz komisch, wie so ein, wenn man diese Lollis isst oder diese Kratzeisen hat man ja so einen ganz blauen, so einen künstlichen Mundraum, das war halt bei dir schwarz, ganz künstlich, ganz seltsam. Ganz strange. Holgry? Holgry, da musst du mal aufklären, was sind die Zwerge in meinem Mund? Das war Stefan Tietze für diese Woche. Vielen Dank. Das war Flo und Tien Will für diese Woche.
Und für nächste Woche. Das reicht für
zwei Wochen, Flo und Tien Will.
Nächste Woche brauche ich mal alleine.
Ja, weil du keinen Bock hast.
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche, macht's gut, wir hören uns nächste Woche.
Auch ich, wenn es wieder heißt
Ohne Intro.
Dürfen wir uns überhaupt nachsuchen, weil wir haben eigentlich keine Rechte daran. So, guck mal, wie es gerade aussieht bei mir. So sieht es gerade aus. Er nimmt schon lange auf und jetzt ist halt bei mir immer so die Glaubensfrage, wenn ich jetzt, warte mal, wenn ich jetzt, weil du beschwerst dich, dass ich abbreche, aber ich weiß nicht, wenn ich jetzt auf Stop drücke, erscheint entweder die Spur rückwirkend oder wir haben nicht aufgenommen. Ich gucke mal drauf.